hey 42 here we've been using the same
Battery Technology for 30 years now and
our lives depend on it your phone laptop
car smoke detectors medical equipment
and so much more but what if I told you
that a deceptively simple but previously
Out Of Reach technology is about to
change your life forever and that's no
exaggeration by the end of this video
you'll discover why we can't continue to
use our current batteries for much
longer and the unbelievable replacement
that will change the way you live your
life and I'm not just talking about
prolonged battery life for your phone
what this new technology will unlock is
so so much more than
that the future of Battery Technology is
much closer than you think and the
outcome might just surprise us all let
me tell you why but first I want to ask
you a question why is this regular old
clay pot from about 0 ad one of the most
important discoveries in human history
to answer that we need to travel back to
to 1936 when this very pot was dug up
along with a bunch of other similar
artifacts in a small Village near
Baghdad Iraq this particular pot which
is believed to be about 2,000 years old
sat in a museum for 2 years just a Dusty
not all that remarkable exhibit amongst
many others also that's what everyone
fought except for one man H when
Austrian archaeologist vilhelm kig first
viewed this vessel he suspected there
was something exceptional about it that
everyone else had missed and he was
right it turns out this 2,000-year-old
clay pot is the first known example of a
battery built by humans now known as the
Baghdad battery it's a fairly
unremarkable thing it's just a clay pot
plugged up with a stopper made of
asphalt sticking through that asphalt is
an iron Rod which is surrounded by a
copper coil and there was also an acidic
residue inside of it suggesting it had
once been filled with grape juice
the grape juice inside the pot was
acidic enough to react with the copper
and iron electrodes which would have
created a small electric current it only
produced a measly 1vt not enough to
power lights or to keep people's 2,000
year old iPhones charged but the Baghdad
battery was never built for any of that
it was probably made to electroplate
small objects with a thin layer of
copper for
decoration but the principle behind this
archaic invention has remained exactly
the same ever since and that very same
principle now Powers
[Music]
Teslas I've been having trouble getting
to sleep recently it's just such a busy
time of year and I've got this huge
workload that runs through my mind
repeatedly every night and the less
sleep I get the less productive I am the
next day so it's just a vicious cycle
luckily I've managed to put an end to my
sleepless nights with the Manta sleep
mask Manta sleep make the best sleep
masks and functional sleep accessories
they work to improve and optimize sleep
to enable Better Lives through better
sleep and regular naps a huge part of
their mission is taking a stand against
hustle culture with their prap movement
it's about rejecting counterproductive
nap shaming corporate BS and reclaiming
what should have always been yours in
the first place Your vitality your body
is wired to nap and for good reason naps
give you energy Focus strength and
Clarity that you don't get when you
grind through the afternoon I often get
sleepy after lunch when I'm at my desk
so I've been loving taking the
occasional nap using Manta sleep mask
and then powering through my work in the
late afternoon The Mask has such a
premium feel to it and a huge amount of
adjustability and I love this Bluetooth
version which has a built-in speaker
head over to the Manta sleep website
using the link in my description below
and use the discount code 42 for 10% off
your cart at checkout and a huge thanks
to mantis sleep for sponsoring this
video
if we boil it down actually don't ever
boil batteries that's a spectacularly
stupid idea a battery consists of a
cathode the positive electrode an anode
the negative electrode and an
electrolyte that allows ions to move
between them usually a liquid gel or
paste in the Bagdad battery the cathode
was the copper cylinder the anode was
the iron rod and the electrolyte with
the grape
juice so you see nothing has changed the
lithium I am battery in your laptop has
a cathode lithium metal oxide an anode
usually graphite and the electrolyte is
a lithium salt
solution sure we've made plenty of
refinements over the years but the
fundamental principles are almost to
Millennia
old modern batteries however didn't
arrive until 1800 when Italian scientist
alesandro Volta stacked alternating zinc
and copper discs separated by pieces of
cardboard soaked in brine to create a
voltaic pile this was the world's first
continuous electrical battery when vola
connected wires to the top and bottom of
his pile a steady flow of electricity
was
produced the next major breakthrough
came in 1859 when French physicist
Gaston Plant built the world's first
rechargeable battery the lead acid
cell then in 1899 Swedish scientist alir
yunger built the first nickel cadmium
battery and it was another 70 years
before we saw the next big step forward
the lithium
battery it's hard to overstate just how
gamechanging the lithium battery was in
the 1970s when it was invented by
Michael wittingham and patented by Exxon
Mobile it was the first battery that was
both rechargeable and capable of
delivering a high voltage it made all
the futuristic portable Tech that we now
use possible
and it's still the foundation of most
modern batteries John B good enough
later expanded on whittingham's Research
to double a capacity of lithium
batteries speaking of which the lithium
battery is pretty good but it's just not
good enough sure we can make even bigger
lithium batteries but there's a
scientific limit on how much energy can
be stored within a given weight of the
host battery and that number is 260 W
hours per kilogram it's pretty decent
considering older Battery Technology sat
at around
75 the latest iPhone 15 Pro is pretty
bloody good it lasts about a day in a
bit on its 12.7 W battery but if Apple
wanted the next iPhone to last for one
week they'd have to put a five times
heavier battery in it I can see it now
introducing the iPhone 16 Pro super
Max the fattest most
powerfullest iPhone we've ever built
but there's a second sort of secret big
invisible barrier to making bigger
better batteries that big Tech doesn't
like to bother your big brain about but
it's a big problem sorry I got a big
carried away there we're running out of
raw materials to make the damn
things according to a really intelligent
scientist that I interviewed to make a
liian battery you need lithium and to
make a nickel cadmium battery you need
nickel
and cadmium and to make a lead acid
battery you need lead and
acid I think you can see where I'm going
with this the problem is none of these
materials grow on trees in a magical
battery Orchid they're all really hard
to come by and require dangerous energy
hungry environmentally shitty mining
processes usually carried out by child
slaves in unsanitary unhealthy
conditions and that's a big problem
because if we're going to build a
battery Revolution we're going to need a
lot more of of these Rare Earth minerals
and our current system just isn't
sustainable or well
good the two primary goals of all new
theoretical batteries are increasing
energy density and decreasing charging
times and there are a few really
exciting new battery technologies that
could change everything I'll tell you
about those in just a minute but first
you've probably already heard of one of
them the battery industry's poster child
I'm talking about solid state unlike
traditional batteries which use a liquid
or gel electrolyte solid state batteries
use a solid
one yeah I know oh I'm sorry were you
expecting laser batteries made from the
tears of alien hamsters it's a minor
change but it's hard to understate just
how revolutionary this tweak will be the
most promising prototypes use a ceramic
electrolyte it's the perfect choice
really since it's highly conductive
allowing ions to easily pass through it
but the biggest Improvement will
actually be in safety current batteries
have two fatal flaws firstly they are
susceptible to Thermal runaway leading
to fires explosions and bad
times secondly lithium based batteries
can form dendrites these are strands of
lithium metal that grow inside the
electrolyte over time if a dendrite
grows so large that it breaches the gap
between the cathode and anode it can
short circuit leading to fires
explosions and bad
times solid state batteries eliminate
both of these concerns ceramic is
chemically inert and extremely stable
under high temperatures so thermal
runaway is no longer an issue and being
solid dendrites will have a tough time
penetrating the
electrolyte solid state batteries
promise energy densities of around 100%
more than lithium primarily because
there's no permanent anode in solid
state batteries reducing the weight by
by almost
50% just think about what that means an
EV vehicle that has a 350 M range today
with the exact same weight would have a
700 mile
range that would basically eliminate the
whole range anxiety argument against
electric cars for those of you who've
never driven an EV that's the concern
that you'll be stranded 100 miles from
the nearest charger because your
manufacturer lied to you and then you
have to ret all your passengers American
company quantum AP is currently fronting
the charge of solid state battery
development but more refinement is
needed to make them stable and operate
consistently it's currently estimated
that we'll see solid state batteries
inside cars and consumer Tech by
2025 but what if there was a simpler
solution to better batteries what if we
could just take lithium ion batteries
and replace one of its primary minerals
Cobalt with a cheaper more abundant and
more effective
alternative there are 118 known elements
surely one of them can provide the
answer Without fire explosions and bad
times well it turns out sulfur might do
just that at least that's the aim of
lithium sulfur
batteries what makes these such a game
Cher is their energy density sulfur the
cafod material is both lightweight and
capable of Hosting much more lithium
ions for comparison prototype sulfur
batteries have demonstrated 550 W kg of
energy density compared to the 260 of
current lithium batteries and it's
likely that that 550 figure will be
increased with further
research sulfur is also abundant and
very low cost in fact it's the 10th most
abundant element in the universe by mass
whereas Cobalt and nickel used in
lithium ion batteries are both
considerably rarer and more difficult to
extract oh and did I mention that there
are countless Labs that have already
built working sort of commercially
viable sulfur batteries right now in
fact we've been working on this concept
since the 60s and our current iterations
are pretty far
Advanced so what givs why aren't our
laptops phones and cars half the weight
with twice the energy well commercially
viable is a loose term and the current
version suffer from very low lifespans
during charge and discharge Cycles the
sulfur cathode tends to dissolve which
leads to a rapid decay in battery
performance over
time another challenge is the shuttle
effect where poly sulfide molecules
shuttle between the cathode and anode
degrading the battery's performance some
prototypes have only demonstrated in the
range of 10 to 30 charging Cycles before
giving up entirely and nobody's going to
buy EV that can be charged 30 times even
if it does have a 1,000 mile
range however rapid improvements are now
being made on reducing these drawbacks
and in the past year there have been
some lithium sulfur batteries produced
that have lifespans in the hundreds of
Cycles instead of
tens by the way the general consensus is
that the target for a battery that is
properly commercially viable is 2,000
Cycles
the most prominent name in the space is
lion a venture capital funded startup
that is building an automated production
line in San hose California specifically
for producing lithium sulfur batteries
with the primary buyers being EV
manufacturers it expects to start
shipping in
2024 if that holds true it would be
extremely exciting and the start of a
portable energy Revolution and yes I
give you permission to return to this
comment section in a year's time to ask
me where the hell all those damn sulfur
batteries actually are and that's the
big question isn't it when if ever will
we see these Technologies in the real
world in our homes and workplaces there
are quite a few other promising battery
technologies on the horizon such as
sodium iron graphine and even Quantum
batteries but like nuclear fusion they
all seem to be just around the corner
let's just hope that corner isn't
actually a bloody Circle and that it
actually has an end but just like
nuclear fusion a new battery technology
is a very high stakes reward we've been
using the same batteries for well over
30 years now a cheaper lighter more
energy dense alternative is proving to
be extremely elusive but if we do crack
that nut it's no exaggeration to say
that the world will change
forever there are the obvious changes
such as electric vehicles with more than
double the range and 5 to 10 minute
charging times laptops phones and
wearables that last for days instead of
just one and we'll see massive
improvements to the stability and
efficiency of the power grid with better
load balancing to prevent power cuts and
more efficient usage of renewable
energy but then there are quite a few
changes that could come from better
batteries that will turn our world
upside down and they might not be
immediately apparent to you let me
explain what if we develop batteries
that are so energy dense so cheap and so
efficient that a remote Village could
obtain one charge it using solar and the
entire Village could then enjoy a steady
uninterrupted supply of close to free
electricity forever obviously solar
would need to become more efficient too
but that's happening in parallel with
better Battery tech for reference
current solar Tech is about 20%
efficient but recent prototypes have
pushed that up to 40%
okay now imagine every community in the
world does the same thing generating and
storing most if not all of their energy
needs suddenly you're looking at a
decentralized energy Network communities
that generate and store more electricity
than they use could sell it back into
the parag grid for a profit and use that
money to improve their
Community this would also ease the
strangle holds that big energy has on
our power bills a power grid built by
the people for the people could mean
that citizens of every nation might
enjoy cheaper cleaner electricity
forever that might all sound a bit
farfetched and utopian and I realize
that things don't always pan out in the
most ideal way but just think for a
moment how much political controversy
Warfare and general shittery is caused
by the global power struggle between
ideologically diverse governments and
the bmic gas oil and electricity company
don't worry I'm not turning into a
hippie I'm just saying that if we can
all generate a little bit of our own
electricity just like some people grow
some of their own food and get the rest
from the supermarket it would reduce the
demand and strain on continent spanning
energy grids that are messy and all too
often a bit bloody Troublesome what if
you didn't have to worry about the next
power cut because you know that you're
in control of your own power supply for
most people the cost and size of the
batteries required for a single
household's needs are the biggest
barrier right now to this ideal scenario
but if we can make those batteries
significantly cheaper lighter and more
energy dense we might just find that
we're all energized with a little spark
of
hope thanks for
watching just a quick word to say that I
couldn't make these videos without the
support of my patreon members consider
joining the exclusive 42 Discord
Community by supporting me on patreon
it's a great place to discuss my videos
with like-minded individuals and myself
the Link's in the description but if you
don't want to or you can't join my
patreon then please don't worry a simple
like or comment to say thanks would also
put a huge smile on my face thank you